best piece of advice in your 20s okay I
wrote this song cuz that was a pretty
hard one to kind of gather this is just
coming from someone that's currently in
her 20s and like hitting the end dis
don't try to pretend you know everything
allow yourself to learn from others
listen to your guts rather than the
group I always used to think that I had
to listen to everybody else and also
watch everybody else seeing how great
they were doing and that made me feel so
discouraged that I thought I was not
doing well and it made my 20s even more
tough to go through because you're
comparing yourself to everybody I was so
s in thinking that I knew exactly who I
was and I knew exactly where I was going
that mindset wore me out because when
things didn't go according to plan
defeat and heartbreak and low
self-esteem settled and we physically
grow in life therefore our minds du too
it changes adapt and learn to figure out
what's needed for true
happiness thank you